Bethan scam it's a date a woman who is
really into yoga and choke sex was like
do you enjoy breathing or donít make up
your mind honestly I think patriotism is
for stupid people who don't have a lot
going on in their life can the few or a
loser who doesn't have a lot of
accomplishments gonna be like well we
come here yeah this is the best here
here yeah yeah yeah yeah patriotism I
think it's funny that Americans will be
like communism never works as if they
didn't spend billions of dollars and
kill millions of people to make sure it
won't work not working
Papa doesn't never works because
whenever people control the means of
production their democratically elected
leaders mysteriously died the smaller
rebel group always finds automatic
weapons and look they hitting themselves
let's go pay they look stupid give a
chance man hey it turns out the greedy
[ __ ] beat up the people striving for
a higher ideal
why don't we trust if Mother Russia guys
I don't trust Russia I don't know what
I'm saying
I think capitalism is fine if you want
to do it but don't make everyone players
do a game I like fortnight I don't make
a grandma play take away our house if
she loses any survival situation that
you put them in except a situation where
everyone has equal rights I kind of
[ __ ] them up
you're gonna stop having a cola sag with
a minority but you can't stop because
surviving a swamp with an alligator you
swish that around living in a car I live
in a car it's a spear man 2014 and it's
drinking that date and an automobile and
now it's all about the push just kidding
it's tributed day even if a day goes
well what usually ends up happening is
we go for a drive
and so I can work up the courage inside
we arrive 45 minutes ago
all right